the neat thing about linear algebra in
general is some very seemingly simple
concepts can be interpreted in a bunch
of different ways and can be shown to
represent different ideas or different
problems and that's what I'm going to do
in this video I'm going to explore the
null space or even better I'm going to
explore the relationship if I have some
vector or some matrix a times some
vector X and that that is equal to the
zero vector and we of course saw in the
last few videos that the null space of a
the null space of a is equal to all of
the vectors X all of the vectors X in RN
so this will have n components this
would have to be an M by n matrix if
this was an M by a matrix I would say
all of the vectors in R a so this this
number right here has to be the same as
that number in order for the matrix
vector multiplication to be valid but
the null space of a is all of the
vectors in RN that satisfy this equation
where if I take a and I multiply it
times any one of the vectors in the null
space I should get the zero vector I
should get the zero vector and this is
going to have M components and we've
seen that in previous this is going to
have the zero vectors I'll put it this
way the zero vector is going to be a
member of our M so that's what our null
space is let's explore it a little bit
we know already that our vector our
matrix can be rewritten like this we
could just write it as a set of column
vectors I could say this right here
that's V one then I'm gonna have V two
and I have n columns so this last column
right here is going to be V sub n so I
could if I if I define my vectors this
way that's the first vector that's the
second vector then I can rewrite my
matrix a I could say a is equal to just
a bunch of column vectors v1 v2 all the
way to VN and multiplying this matrix
times a vector X so times X so times x1
x2 all the way to xn we've seen in the
past on the matrix
vector product definition video that
this can be interpreted as this is I
mean this is actually just comes
straight out of the definition this is
the same thing as X 1 X 1 times vector 1
times the first column plus X 2 times
the second column times that column all
the way to and you just keep adding them
up all the way to X n all the way to xn
times the nth column this just comes
straight out of our definition of matrix
vector products now if we're saying that
ax is equal to 0 so if we're saying that
ax is equal to 0 we're looking for the
solution set to that if we're looking
the solution set to ax is equal to 0
then that means is equal to the 0 vector
that that means that this sum that this
sum we're trying to find the solution
set of this sum is equally 0 we want to
figure out the X 1 X 2 X 3s all the way
to xn that make this equal the 0 vector
and what are we doing we're taking
linear combinations of our column
vectors we're taking linear combinations
of our column vectors and seeing if we
can take some linear combination and get
it to the 0 vector now this should start
ringing bells in your head this this
little equation or this little
expression right here should start
ringing bells this was this was part of
our part of what how we defined what
linear independence was we said we said
that if this was the definition of
linear independence when we proved this
fell out of the definition of linear
independence that if I have a bunch of
vectors v1 v2 all the way to VN we say
that they are linearly linearly
independent linearly independent there's
kind of the the non mathematical way of
describing it is well I guess this is
mathematical as well is that look none
of the vectors can be represented as a
combination of the other ones and then
we show that that means that the only
solution to this equation would be that
x1 x2 all of the coefficients on this
has to be equal to zero that this is the
only solution linear independence means
that this is the only solution to this
to this equation right now if the only
way that you get the zero vector by
taking combination of all of these
column vectors it's the only way to do
that is to have all of these guys equal
zero then you are linearly independent
likewise if these if v1 v2 all the way
to VN are linearly independent then the
only solution to this is for these
coefficients to be zero and we saw that
in our video on linear independence now
if all of these coefficients are 0 what
does that mean that means that means
that our vector X that our vector X is
the 0 vector is the V 0 vector and only
the 0 vector that's the only solution so
we have something interesting here if
our column vectors are linearly
independent if v1 v2 all the way to VN
are linearly independent linearly
independent then that means that the
only solution to ax equals 0 ax equals 0
only solution only solution and solution
is that X has to be equal to 0 vector or
put another way the solution set of this
equation which is really just a null
space the null space is all of the X's
that satisfy this equation so that the
null space of a has to only contain the
0 vector so that's an interesting result
if we're linear independent then the
null space of a only contains the 0
vector which is another way of saying
that let me write this that X well I
already wrote it down that x1 x2 all of
them have to be equal to 0 now if I were
to multiply this equation out and get it
into reduced row echelon form what does
that mean we saw in a previous video
that the null space of a is equal to the
null space of the reduced
reduced row echelon form of a and that's
the null space of a is 0 because it's
column vectors are each linear
independent and that means that the null
space of the reduced row echelon form of
a must also equal the 0 vector and that
means that if I take the reduced row
echelon form of a times maybe I'm being
a little redundant the reduced row
echelon form of a and I multiply that
times X times or I want to solve this I
want to solve this equation the only
solution right here is X is equal to X
is equal to the 0 vector and if you
think about what that means that if this
is the only solution that means that
this reduced row echelon form has no
free variables it literally would just
have to look like this it would have to
look like this so this is X x1 x2 all
the way to xn the reduced row echelon
form of a in order for in order for this
to have a unique solution and that
unique solution being 0 the reduced
echelon form is going to have to look
like this it's going to have to look
like this 1 times x1 plus 0 times all
the other ones so you're going to have
just a bunch of you're gonna have n
zeros and then you're gonna have 1 times
x2 plus zeros times everything else and
those ones are going to go all the way
down the diagonal so it's going to look
like that and then that is going to be
equal to the 0 vector and what is and
this is going to be a square matrix
where this is has to be n and this has
to be n how do I know that because I
said that X 1 X 2 and all of these have
to be equal to 0 so if they have to be
equal to 0 if I write if I write just
write them as a system of equations if I
write X 1 is equal to 0 X 2 is equal to
0 X 3 is equal to 0 all the way to X n
is equal to 0 this this system of
equations if I wrote it as an Augmented
matrix remember this is X 1 plus 0 let
me write plus 0 X 2 plus 0 this as an
Augmented matrix and we've done this
small
times it would look like this one you
just have a bunch of zeros and zeros and
then the ones would just go down the
diagonal and then you'd have n zeros
right there so that's where I'm getting
it from that if we are linearly
independent the null space of our of a
is going to be just a zero vector and if
the null space of a is just a zero
vector then the null space of the
reduced row echelon form is only the
zero vector
the only solution is all of the x is
equal to 0 which means the reduced row
echelon form of a has to essentially
just be ones down the diagonal with
zeros everywhere else so anyway I just
wanted to make this you know this is
kind of a neat byproduct of an
interpretation of the null space let me
write that so if the null space let me
write our summarize our results the null
space of a if it just equals 0
then that means you could go both ways
that's true if and only if the column
vectors column vectors of a are linearly
linearly independent independent and all
of that's only true oh this is true if
you know all of maybe I was going to do
a triangle with my turn to a square if
x1 x2 all of these have to be equal 0
this is the only solution only solution
and then that implies that the reduced
that implies that the reduced
row-echelon and I kind of well I didn't
do it maybe as precisely as I would have
liked but the reduced row echelon form
of a is essentially going to be a square
n by n matrix and by n matrix and by the
way this is this can only be true if
we're dealing with an N by n matrix to
begin with and maybe I'll do that a
little bit more precisely in a future
video but then the reduced row echelon
form of a is going to have to look like
there's just a bunch of ones down the
diagonal with zeros everywhere else and
these all imply each other now
what if the the the null space of a
contains some other vectors well then it
would be then we would have to say that
the column vectors of a are linearly
dependent and if they're linearly
independent then we wouldn't have a
reduced row echelon form of a that
looked like this you would have
something that would have some free
variables that allows you to create more
solutions there anyway I just wanted to
give you this angle on on how you can
interpret the null space and how it
relates to linear independence